je sortis ces monocoques est venu
l'accueillir d'accord l'année quand ils
direction la plage une super news après
on prend la maison on a bougé les
vêtements non pas ses vêtements qui
m'avait déjà acheté je me suis changé
ça me donne un peu des petits conseils
au gabon
le passage à 100 familles parfois vu
comme une mesure de la santé quelque
chose de morehead encore les gens
sortent deux cents familles souvent la
première chose c'est d'aller se laver le
corps comme le mans comme on dit qu'est
ce que tu penses de cette thérapie
oui c'est vrai c'est quelque chose qui
est qui ce fait je pense que c'est bien
si ça permet de se sentir mieux et 2
oui c'est pourquoi pas bon moi je n'ai
pas je n'ai pas fait mais je pense que
dans la culture gabonaise et c'est
important c'est un geste symbolique qui
est important je l'avais le corps la
sortie des présences et du fétichisme à
particules ainsi sortie de crise on sait
que j'ai eu une piste mouillée c'est de
la bonne conscience et avec la grâce et
du gilet fait et je me sens bien
eli va tabler au bord de mer pour faire
quoi
si j'écris ce temps moi je suis la levée
de toute iniquité je suis lavé de tout
je suis une nouvelle créature
[Rires]
[Musique]
sans famille c'est ça évoque beaucoup de
choses puisque c'est d'abord un lieu ici
qui est appelé sa famille s'il est
appelé sans famille c'est bien pour pour
une raison particulière c'est que les
gens qui y sont
justement sont éloignés de leur famille
ne bénéficient pas souvent du soutien de
leur famille donc ce lieu c'est bien
entendu la prison centrale de libreville
mieux que j'ai connus suite à suite à un
accident
j'ai pu passer un an avec d'autres avec
d'autres détenus
moi sa famille s'ils consultent et déjà
abandonné
vêtements sans famille c'est à dire
qu'on utilise un ta famille chanté par
un santé à mickey sposato nous au dehors
avant que je n'aille apriso savais pas
que la prison centrale a fait appel et
sans famille
c'est quand je suis arrivé enfin en
prison que j'ai je suis que l'on
appelait la prison centrale s'en fallut
soient bons doigts c'est un autre monde
sans famille c'est une dénomination qui
est qu'il quitterait près ancien qui est
très ancienne chaussure depuis le début
depuis le début mais c'est aussi la
prise de conscience que le détenu
finalement est un homme mais manque
manquent à l'appel il n'est plus des
nôtres
c'est ce qu'on pense il n'est plus des
nôtres il est dans un enclos
il est entre quatre murs dans une
cellule il est coopi et les jo ont
toujours en tête n'ont pas cet homme qui
existe encore dans un enclos
mais surtout ce en tête ce qu'il a fait
la période de sortie la période après la
sortie est prévue pour ceux se réinsérer
et se re faire accepter par la famille
et par par les collègues par les
connaissances moi je sais que ça a été
j'ai vécu une année très difficile
la sortie parce que les personnes que
vous connaissiez
par exemple j'ai voulu remettre
emplacement mon entreprise reprendre mon
entreprise reprendre mes contacts avec
avec les clients que j'avais et ça a été
très dur parce que certains ont tendance
à vous rejetez en disant non il a été il
a été en prison c'est pas quelqu'un de
fréquentable
donc ça a été un travail un travail
assez dur puis redémarrez souvent sans
moyens avec rien vous êtes donc je me
suis retrouvé à devoir prendre le taxi
aller re des marchés mes clients à
croiser certains compatriotes que je
connaissais qui avance arrêté me disait
bonjour qui au départ aquila me disais
plus beaux jours passés en voiture sans
s'arrêter
et c'est oui il faut reconquérir
il faut refaire sa place je vais dire
dans dans la société
l'entreprise aujourd'hui est en pleine
ascension donc
en général je débute le matin à 7 heures
je m'occupe
de l'atelier de donner des instructions
matin jusqu'à 10h en gros 10 11e et les
soudeurs ne sommes pas là comment ça
c'est les pieds des baby foots d'accord
vous allez passer en peinture
ensuite je traite un certain nombre de
dossiers administratifs et je consacre
en général d'après midi au rendez vous
je vais également régulièrement sur le
terrain voir les actions des équipes
[Applaudissements]
si celle d'amiens d'après vite la faire
le trou c'est qu'a menées le camion
podium bordeaux ne sait rien encore
installés et puis on est à notre scène
[Musique]
en réinsertion au niveau social ça veut
dire des amis disent on a des gens avec
qui tu es est-ce qu'on ait rejeté est-ce
qu'on a été rayé à ct et de notre cadre
le boulot qui seront faits pour se
battre au quotidien par rapport à vos
amis que j'avais c'est vrai que ça ne
manque que j'avais tous ne peuvent pas
avoir le même regard
et moi j'ai refusé qu'on me regarde avec
un certain regard' soit 2 mais pris soin
de détails
je termine à voir avec mamie la petite
maison et puis généralement vers 9h09 un
engagement au magasin au jeu j'exerce ma
petite activité soit si je ne me rends
pas peut-être que je peux avoir un
marché
parfois ils ont commandé des choses je
bouge pas là le magasin fermé mais si on
doit en dehors de ça dont je suis ont
marché toute la journée ça veut dire de
10h à 18h je suis à messi j'ai autre
chose à faire je peux me déplacer plus
que ça
bonjour
la sortie des besoins de soi ça que tu
prends la bonne voie soit tu suis la
mauvaise voie tant que dans le
banditisme le banc cache tout le monde
dit que montage judicieux a été touché
quand je pourrai jamais travaillé comme
tout le monde à part des petites
bricoles cher est de 6 heures hier max
dubois est ce que ça te plaît de faire
ce travail du moment là où ça met au
monde
en tout cas mes plats riches y travaille
et que tout peut pas revenir sur mes
petits besoins mais qui allaient
chercher ailleurs mien attendent que les
amis à y faire ça on peut éviter les
ennuis dans vos me bricoler ça me permet
aussi de l'aider mais fait rare au
quartier et par le matin je reçois pour
moi et aux familles
avec moi ne risque pas de conduire dans
la course auto russe mais on peut on
signer cet accord
il n'était pas question de tap c'était
une question de principe et ce coquin de
ce dialogue avec le pm l'élection est
bien préparée verte vraiment de vous
présenter le problème n'est pas de
l'ordre du jour
je vais
son image sur la plante beige
j'ai appris ce métier tu as à sang fanny
angénieux midi car je fais trop
maladroits pu et su sortir par le racing
avait décidé d'approfondir nos métiers
et a reçu un certificat de formation les
fans et un certificat de fin de
formation
j'ai été soumis à un problème g callen
fumeurs et je suis tombé gravement
malade j'étais à l'infirmerie
sanou à l'affût mairie à 20 là bas un
lavabo qui était bouché je ne
connaissais pas le métier
les infirmières nous il nous est demandé
l'ailé gauche le lavabo plus que c'est
nous qui les utilisent
je suis allée vieux démons telle aussi
forte je ne savais pas encore ce que
c'était j'ai démonté le siphon avait de
la salle talent qui verra j'ai nettoyé
peu après le passé c'est à ce moment là
et je me suis essayé de faire ce métier
là
le moment je me sens un précieux travail
de toutes formes faux témoins monsieur
au sénat à gauche et fera chauffer
taxibus j'épargne c'est un somme
d'argent qui m'a permis de payer mon nom
et passage à l'auto-école enfin de quoi
passer un examen malheureusement j'ai
raté mon premier c'est dur mais j'ai
gagné ce pas que
note
j'ai eu des parents notamment mon père
qui était directeur de prison dans le
fils d'anciens directeurs de prison
ayant vécu dans les prisons sans avoir
été en prison parce que le diatta de la
prison a un domicile d'astreinte et donc
j'y ai vécu j'ai vu j'ai côtoyé beaucoup
de prisonniers où j'ai quasiment été en
prison sans avoir ils étaient chacun
peut se retrouver un jour ou l'autre
dans une situation bizarre et se
retrouver en prison
voyez vous remarqué prenez votre
véhicule par un beau matin
vous sortez de votre maison mais il peut
arriver que vous ayez un accident de
circulation vous fauché deux ou trois
enfants mais avant de savoir si vous
avez raison ou pas vous irez d'abord un
prix
[Musique]
je me suis retrouvé à 100 familles
arrêtez pas l'agenda mairie d'une tour
où j'ai été déférés en prison centrale
vous parlez de la justice de libreville
où j'ai été mis sous mandat dépôt et mis
en prison
on y avait beaucoup d'ail des agents en
danger un pick up avec mes amis du
quartier n'ont pas surcharger oui ne pas
chercher à comprendre monsieur n'aime
pas respecté
on est embarqué bain n'est pas tout
comme serial a parlé elle a dormi en
série sanesi torturé pendant une semaine
arrivé là bas on va pas laisser tomber
mes mamies aussi j'ai fait pratiquement
deux semaines à bas les parents ne
venait pas au bout du monde dixième jour
j'ai fait avec des kits anciens ceux du
commun qui montre qu'on points convertis
tu souffres à canon et achètent tous les
matins quelque chose que tu ne connais
pas acep seulement tu parles prison à
prison n'est pas une fin en soi comme ça
et à sète les motifs ou qu'on arrête de
me taper et on a vu notre finale est
signé le mandat de dépôt et puis je me
suis retourné
c'est vrai qu'en général on vous emmène
dans un couloir
on frappe certains pas tous
en fait vous déshabiller on vous enlève
tous les objets que vous avez sur vous
et puis on vous rase je veux dire
quelque part je n'aurais pas laissé le
temps de faire tout ça c'est à dire qu'à
peine je suis rentré de moi même je me
suis déshabillé de moi même j'ai demandé
une lame pour me raser pour une femme
perdre ses cheveux c'est simple c'est un
peu difficile c'est vrai que c'était pas
le plus important a les cheveux donc
après tu m'as donné une celui ci je peux
appeler ça comme ça on appelle
généralement ses lunes mais ce ne sont
pas des cellules ce sont des débloque
ce sont des blocs où tu as deux à trois
détenus qui y sont et puis vous partager
c'est comme si c'était un petit un petit
séjour 3
je suis arrivé dans un dans une cellule
où il était assez nombreux dizaine une
cellule ses quatre murs trois mètres sur
3 9 mètres carrés avec une porte
du moins une ouverture qui c'est une
ouverture de qui sert de porte
une fenêtre et puis des matelas au sol
et des matelas aller sur un support 1
mètre 50 au dessus donc avec des détenus
qui dorment en bas et des tenues qui
dorment sur la paillasse ou dessus
autour des deux autres autour des gens
sortent je peux te retrouver à une
période où il ya beaucoup de rentrer ou
tout l'autre avec 100 femmes oui à
beaucoup de sorties aussi vous retrouver
parfois ce sont même parfois à 50 c'est
possible
donc vous allez de 200 salariés deux
sens entre 50 et 100 on se retrouve à
proximité d'autres personnes qu'on ne
connaît pas qui ont pas forcément
les mêmes règles de vie les mêmes
manières de se comporter qui n'ont pas
eu les mêmes et la même éducation
et ensuite il faut au moins ça a été mon
cas il faut trouver rapidement
des idées des manières de s'occuper
d'occuper son temps pour ne pas se
morfondre assise sur son matelas
[Musique]
j'ai entrepris pas mal d'action
d'une part parce que j'ai certaines
conditions j'ai trouvé certaines d'un
certaines choses qui étaient qui était
je vais dire anormal
dans un milieu où vivaient 1500
personnes pratiquement donc par exemple
quand je suis arrivé il n'y avait pas
d'eau on allait
à tour de rôle puiser l'eau dans la cour
intérieure avec un saut alors que des
canalisations existait mais n'avait pas
été entretenu voilà donc à l'époque
j'avais fait un courrier au directeur
pour me lui demander l'autorisation de
remettre en état ses canalisations et le
système d'eau alors ça ça a surpris la
démarche a surpris parce qu'il ne sommes
comme des passes de ça deux jeunes
détenus
mais j'ai été écouté et donc le
directeur marc autorisée j'ai vu que
j'avais ma structure à l'extérieur ma
société à l'extérieur j'ai demandé au
personnel de la société de bien vouloir
fournir le matériel que nous avions pour
nous aider à remettre en état le réseau
d'eau donc on a on a remis l'eau est il
par la suite les détenus pouvaient se
doucher à l'intérieur des cellules
il ya beaucoup de loisy t1 prison je me
souviens quand j étais un moment donné
nous avons voulu créer une petite je ne
peux pas appeler les seuils de
l'association une petite structure je
sais pas comment donner le nom adéquat
mais on voulait occuper des détenus et
moi je m'occupais des femmes dans le
tricotage dans le la fabrication des
défauts la tripotage défaut là avec du
fil ou de la laine mais hier il n'y a
pas trop chose y'a pas grand chose on
avait créé un petit un petit comité
avec marie louise qui était responsable
d'atelier chez les femmes et moi qui
étais responsable chez les hommes on
avait mis en place un président
secrétaire général voilà et on faisait
des réunions régulières où on présentait
au directeur ce qui était fait quelles
étaient nos besoins
et l'activité de l'atelier alors j'ai
plusieurs documents et même tu vois un
tableau fait par les détenus
[Musique]
dans l'atelier artisanal donc on avait
initié un certain nombre de d'activité
et ça c'était donc le tissage surtout tu
sais on dessine on fait un dessin et
ensuite il tente du fil il ya tout un
tas de deux dessins de différents
dessins donc ça c'était fait c'était
fait là bas je me suis beaucoup occupé
des jeunes des mineurs
qui se retrouve là
16 ans 17 ans 18 ans pour des des
forfaits il faut fait mineur je dirais
et qui souvent sont des jeunes qui sont
là parce que il leur manquait une
certaine éducation
ils se sont ils ont été non pas été
scolarisés et donc il est important de
profiter de ce temps là pour les pour
les éduquer j'avais mis en place à
l'intérieur des cours donc je me suis
appuyé sur des détenus adultes qui
étaient des enseignants qui se
retrouvaient là pour des diverses choses
et que j'ai coopté on a créé plusieurs
classes et on avait mis en place des
cours d'alphabétisation
des cours pour les 5e 4e des cours de
français les cours de me les autres et
on avait beaucoup de monde qui
adhéraient à ses cours et qu'ils étaient
intéressés par par ces formations
le fait aussi de mettre en place la
bibliothèque j'ai été extrêmement
surpris de voir que
les personnes incarcérées s'intéresser
énormément aux livres de sciences
naturelles et autres de des classes de
6e de sixième terminal vous avez il y
avait une soif d'apprendre une soif de
connaître qui est qui est importante
c'était pas facile du tout bien sûr
j'étais habitué à être partout à me
lever le matin est très libre d'aimer
entrées et sorties et me retrouver
quelque part où j'avais qu'une petit
espace c'est vraiment compliqué c'était
compliqué c'était même très très
difficiles moments de part et par moment
donné tu pense au suicide
tu penses possible mais tu n'appelles
possible s'était suicidé mais tout
devient facile quand tu rencontres les
choix
jésus christ de nazareth c'est la quille
qui vient mettre un bon moteur et c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec moi pour nous
pour voir le temps qui passe
on s'est pas occupé à l'élu kanouté
ducation spirituelle et morale en
méditant sur la parole les yeux en
lisant la parole et lieux et en recevant
les enseignements des saintes écritures
à l'aller jonas en famille c'est
vraiment fini
c'est d'abord dans ta on passe du temps
à poser
on s'est vu un peu d'eau à 6 ha
c'est un passage des mairies sauf qu'ils
doivent aller la cour tout le quartier
deux thèmes qui font du à la vaisselle
place déjà qu'ils font derrière
mécanisme
il peut par déjà deux places à pourvoir
pour vendre d'autres qui font la corvée
d'eau sont et l'épousé de nouveau
d'autres qui changent arrive pas c'est
un peu du temps à lire bavarde et la
sécurité seule la toiture faisait quoi
noah fait du vent délavés mon petit
encore vous donner à cigarette
tous les moyens étaient mieux pour moi
sans famille parce que premièrement
c'était ma première du faux halal est là
bas et j'étais troublé je n'avais pas le
moral et temps là bas je suis tombé
gravement malade
ac j'ai souffert d'une infection
pulmonaire que les jeux étaient très
amir faute l'occupation ni à l'âge où je
me trouvais les enseignements
j'ai passé mon temps l'hymne habib et
quelques heures a ajouté je pouvais m'en
procurer le midi et soir c'était
difficile à vivre à cause du bruit de
recherches de l'uni vous êtes dans des
cellules et vous avez des droits de
sortie dans les couloirs par exemple ou
pour d'autres dans la cour intérieure et
c'est quand on vous fait rentrer de ces
couloirs ou de cette cour de cette cour
quand on vous fait rentrer en cellule ou
l'ass et c'est dur parce que du coup
votre couloir
c'était un espace de liberté le petit
couloir que vous aviez dans lequel on
vous a autorisé à aller c'était un
espace de liberté quand le soir on vous
dit rentrer dans votre cellule à nouveau
vous ressentez l'enfermement
le moment le plus dur c'est c'est la
nuit à se refermer blocs à 19 heures
alors retour aux fermes le bloc à 19
heures ça veut dire tous ne voient plus
la lune tu me vois plus le ciel et vous
êtes dans votre bloc et les nus sont
très nombreux
en ce qui concerne la beauté extérieure
celle qu'il veut se tresser elle se
dresse entre mais non pour celles qui ne
veulent pas se tresser elles ont des
cheveux coupés
il faudrait que tu la cour de tenue des
devises le maison que joliment pressés
parce que tu n'as pas de miracle
pourrait pas tenir
donc quand je me regarde quand l'autre
est pressé jeudi s de ccm demandé ce que
ça va vite vu que je ne m'en pressé et
ainsi de suite
comment les gens faisaient pour vivre
leur sexualité parce que si tu dois
rester beurre on ne vit pas de sexualité
en prison
il n'y a pas si tu es resté 25 ans de
prison moins cher ses vingt cinq ans
d'abstinence visiteurs d'abstinence est
bien de chez nous c'est quoi le 6 l de
terrain n'a pas une vie sexuelle mais la
sexualité c'est un besoin physiologique
donc comment ils comment ils font alors
je sais pas vous énumérer tous je vous
dise quelque chose que vous aimeriez un
pont vous voulez que je vous dise
surtout mon jeu s'est alors je veux que
tu me dises ce que tu sais ce que je
sais ce que le détenu
ça peut être où c'est ça peut être c'est
un besoin je suis d'accord avec vous
mais le détenu n'a pas de vie sexuelle
il est détenu
ça veut dire il est là si c'est arrivé
ailleurs moi je parcours des sens mais
mais un nom six mois de prison
ce n'est pas vécu ça je n'ai pas vu
quelqu'un vivre c'est un peuple
est ce ce qui se passe là bas en milieu
carcéral comme t'as pas de visite pour
la famille tu abandonnes d'obliger des
mandats aux gens
né à des vieux prisonnier qui pensent
autrement
donc ils sont montés sur livres n'ont
fait ce n'était pas bien
voici les lycées dans le journal c'est
le petit pour la violer en prison à
[Musique]
personnes qui venaient lui rendre visite
à l'autre pardon il y avait vraiment
personnes qui visitent place à moi je
peux dire que ce sont les prisonniers
qui gardent des pionniers l'épousé n'est
que cadet cuisine est passé apparemment
les gardiens d'une prison son palais de
travail
c'est la fête il ya vraiment un truc qui
se passe ça va c'est quand mu ont déjà
fumé la baie aujourd'hui j'ai dit car
après chercha d'éveil s'est défoulé sur
les gens c'est vraiment pas bien
c'est vraiment pénible ce soient les
plus connus comme nous qui nous rend
donc à la plus en plus dur enfin il y
avait des moments quittant colis
arrivent comme ce sont les grands et les
vieux prisonnier il tarde à chocolat ou
sa passivité vis est à présent que tu
puisses tu dis vrai enfin dans un grand
quart
je comprends pas que j'embarque doit
entamer l'imposant qu'une correction qui
arrive donc à braquer la barre comprends
rien du tout voyant pas s'il ya des
vrais couteau de cuisine qui font entrer
de 4 à 6 août les jeunes sans appel
selon les pots cassés
[Musique]
vous ne pouvez pas dans une seule et
même prison y fourrer et le mot je le
prononce ces jeux il faudrait y fourrer
des prévenus donc des personnes qui
n'ont jamais été condamnés qui n'ont
jamais été jugés avec des personnes qui
a été jugé et condamné avec à
l'intérieur n'a pas parlé des mineurs de
cette catégorie de personnes les mineurs
il foulé également les femmes et dire il
faudrait aussi j'ai oublié certains
détenus qui devrait être dans une maison
de haute sécurité
c'est un détenu dangereux est réputé
dangereux dans la seule et même prison
non ce n'est pas faire de la bonne
politique pénitentiaire
ce problème est vraiment très très très
graves et compromet compromet
la ville à la réinsertion de nombre de
jeunes
c'est un problème de la justice
gabonaise qui ne fonctionne pas qui ne
fonctionnent pas correctement
reconnaissons-le nos prisons sont
bondées de monde aujourd'hui parce que
une prison qui a été conçu pour 300
personnes aujourd'hui il y en a mille
cinq cents ça veut dire que les places
n'existe plus les places se sont
réduites davantage il y à tout le monde
mais on va pas les vies des bottes par
des glaces présidentielle non
ban
gavin questions à vous poser suis bon
faites moi j'ai même campus pour ceux
qui sont en milieu carcéral
c'est en fait y en a deux que qu'on
finit la peine mais ils sont quand la
barque
l'état de danse donc il y en a deux
parfois qu'ils vont même encore quatre
ans de plus alors pour moi vraiment ça
me touche on met tous moments
le prévenu n'est pas encore jugé il
bénéficie de la présomption d'innocence
comment voulez vous mettre les halles
dans un cachot exécrable cas qui n'a
même pas encore été jugé au point que
parfois cette personne peut même être
relaxé après six mois de détention
ouais c'est incroyable c'est incroyable
c'est pourquoi justement là aussi la
justice vosloo faire très attention on
ne décide pas à la légère d'un mandat
d'arrêt on ne dessine pas cela la légère
parce que non seulement vous perdez la
personne de ses moyennes boulot on va
dire de sa capacité locomotive la
liberté d'aller et venir est entravée
deuxièmement vous le mettez dans une
cellule
on ne sait pas ce qu'il va y subir alors
même qu'il bénéficie la présomption
d'innocence à supposer qu'ils soient
torturés déjà où frapper mais pour rien
finalement
et que plus tard on découvre que ce
n'est pas lui qui devait se retrouver là
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait de ce
préjudice moral important et parfois
physiques subis six mois durant dans une
maison de détention on fait quoi de sa
qui paye
[Musique]
et
il n'a plus la cote
toujours pas du racing tu dois je faire
[Applaudissements]
ces 1300 mois
après on verra sur place moi j'aime
groupe est sonorisé forme arriver quelle
surprise
et toi ça va tout mais eux mêmes c'est
cette nouvelle année mercier toi je
passais par là ce matin je suis allé
faire une fiction je suis d'accord que
je fasse un loto dimanche
oui moi c'est gentil c'est vrai que ça
fait un moment qu'on sait quand c'est
pas vu ya déjà des choses à faire on
peut faire quelque chose il ya beaucoup
à faire
il ya beaucoup moi j'avais même
rencontré des chefs d'entreprise
notamment au niveau de son combat et
schubert fric qu'ils étaient prêts et
éventuellement à prendre des jeunes en
sortie de ce sens existent et même ton
projet j'en avais discuté avec eux et
ils étaient prêts en me disant si il ya
une cellule un psychologue est capable
de les voir un peu et de nous assurer
qu'il n'y a pas trop de problèmes
on est prêt à prendre ces jeunes un
stage pendant cinq six mois pour qu'ils
se réinsèrent pas forcément les
embauchés définitivement mais au moins
ça leur met un pied à l'étrier et
pendant ce temps là ça ça leur apprend à
travailler à savary aussi de locaux
trois là et puis cela permet entre temps
de retrouver du travail
il faut que je vois mais c'est vrai que
ça demande beaucoup de
beaucoup de temps et
au moins avec l'entreprise je suis aussi
je suis aussi à ce prix
donc c'est pas évident mais je vais on
va se revoir et puis on va essayer
d'avancer un pion d'avancer là dessus il
faut que nous ayons à la fois une
politique pénale et post pénale digne de
solan mais comme nous avions aussi des
associations formé de personnes civiles
à caumont clé une association quelconque
on devrait aussi pouvoir créer cette
association pour accueillir les détenus
leur trouver des emplois auprès des
entreprises
n'est ce pas donc c'est une association
qui pourrait avoir des partenariats avec
des entreprises de la place place et
nous les replacer car vous savez dans
les prisons dans toutes les prisons du
monde il y a une main d'oeuvre
extraordinaire vous avez à l'intérieur
des médecins vous avez des maçons vous
avez des menuisiers vous avez toutes
sortes de métiers tous les métiers la
plupart sont représentés dans une prison
il faut des partenariats clean et
parthenay la banque
l'institution pénitentiaire et des
entreprises pour créer une passerelle un
intéressant de socialisation du détenu
il faut que le détenu
même quand ils travaillent à supposer
qu'on crée une espèce de semi liberté
quand il va dehors pour travailler non
dieu il faut qu'ils aient un petit
salaire qu'on appelle en termes
pénitentiaire le pécule il faut qu'ils
aient un pécule pour lui permettre aussi
de penser qu'au maintien au oui j'ai
travaillé je suis payé cet argent là on
peut le mettre en réserve une partie de
cet argent peut le mettre en réserve au
greffe de la prison centrale pour le lui
restituer
lorsqu'il sort de prison ça peut lui
permettre d'avoir un premier pedestal
pour espérer vivre après l'otan de
trouver un emploi et le temps de se
stabiliser
depuis que je suis sorti j'ai repris en
fait j'ai continué à soutenir l'atelier
artisanat
en fournissant du matériel lors d'un
visite régulièrement en trouvant des
clients pour les produits qui étaient
étaient fournis
je continue j'ai fait plusieurs dons de
livres pour que les détenus puissent
puisse lire et s'informer
1000 points sans famille je n'ai pas en
restant à la maison en disant mais non
je pense je prie pour eux mais de temps
en temps même dans la peur d'être
français au président bozizé
parce que le sûr de le demande
et parfois il ya beaucoup qui sont que
l'on personnes ou les familles et sont
elles sont abandonnées et non personne
en dehors donc
et quand tu y vas c'est un p tit
soutiennent elle a besoin de se sentir
aussi aimé parce que c'est ça les gens
ne meurent pas en prison parce qu'il
manque à mon vélo
les gens meurent en prison parce qu'ils
ont été abandonnés
est ce que tu penses que le fait d'être
passé à 100 familles a influencé ta vie
d'aujourd'hui
oui je pense que ça m'a mis plus aller
coûte beaucoup plus à l'écouté des
autres
oui et ça m'a permis de mieux comprendre
la culture la culture gabonaise
aujourd'hui moi je dis pas je sais pas
les autres sur quoi il s'approche mais
moi je m'accrochais christ jésus christ
de nazareth
je ne me couche pas je m'approche pas un
homme ni à la sagesse humaine le je veux
je souhaiterais que toutes nos temps qui
me reste à vivre de marcos ya triste
parce que je sais ce qu'il a fait dans
la vie
[Musique]
je ne peux pas tourner la page pour eux
si je suis allé en prison ce n'était pas
un hasard
je crois c'est un plan c'était pour moi
le seigneur peut-être au dehors
il avait sa main tendue mais je n'aurai
pas cette marque et je crois qu'ils leur
du permis que j'y aille pour être allé
tout seul
satan
[Musique]
mon rêve se dit wenning grandes stars
pénienne grand footballeur
comme tous deux ont d'ailleurs la même
marqué l'histoire par le marathon mais
va aussi à la télé comme tout le monde a
envie de réaliser ça
les jeux que j'allais sortir s'était
senti vraiment un ces parts c'est
vraiment trop content ça va mon soutif
de voir l'arrivée hâtive
c'est vraiment content très content mais
s'ils étaient surpris gars savaient pas
que j'allais sortir et j'étais vraiment
content c'était en fait tout le monde et
être au point de me voir quoi y avait
tellement de la joie de me revoir
j'ai eu un sentiment les joueurs je vais
sécurité et une trentaire parce que
j'avais laissé mon une étape qui
paraissait très difficile oui nous
retrouver les mains donné la force du
régime
on se marchait je voulais à pleins
poumons je voudrais respirer cet air de
la liberté et il y avait quatre fleurs
un bon je coupais j'y mets un peu pour
moi et puis ça faisait un bon bout de
temps je l'avais pas vu de plan symbole
que j'ai marcher marcher tout seul
puisque je l'avais rien sur moi j'avais
tout laissé avec les autres font des
tonnes d'autres je marche est comme ça
j'ai marché
je longeais le mur de la prison
jusqu'à 1 pt carrefour
dessine moi la liberté pouvait tout
seulement
[Musique]
m